le rôle des scientifiques parce que dans
cette histoire les scientifiques ont
joué comme un rôle énorme en
on les a beaucoup vu sur les plateaux de
télévision voilà limites vont tant mieux
parce que leur avis importe mais les
scientifiques se sont transformés en
politique voilà alors tout d'un coup on
a vu des scientifiques nous disent qu'il
fallait confiné qu'il fallait mettre des
couvre-feux qu'il fallait mettre des
masques aux gens de l'extérieur en tout
cas et qu'il fallait mettre des passes
mais moi je redis c'est quelque chose
que je dis beaucoup c'est que les
scientifiques ne sont pas légitimes pour
moi à défendre des mesures qui sont des
mesures politiques qui répondent à des
critères démocratiques et tic
socio-économique monstrueux ça dépasse
de très loin la question scientifique et
je crois que les scientifiques qu avec
notamment le conseil scientifique mais
pas seulement etc on joue un rôle
immense dans cette histoire parce que
ils ont en quelque en quelque sorte
légitimé les mesures les plus
autoritaires au nom de la science qui se
discute pas voilà et c'est là aussi le
grand problème démocratique qu'on a
connu c'est que il n'y a pas eu de
filtres démocratique entre le
faire on va dire les points de vue
scientifique voilà et le filtre
normalement qui doit s'opérer qui le
filtre politique qui répond à plein
d'autres enjeux que les seuls dangers
sanitaires donc je pense que c'est une
responsabilité collective en voilà et
les français voilà mais la science
sociale joue un rôle dans cette histoire
[Musique]